welcome to the final great saga of one
piece we have made it we are officially
in the endgame now the marines
demonstrate their immense power shanks
finally reveals his true face and sabo
has risen to almost as much fame as
luffy has across the world in other
words pure one piece greatness so four
terrible weeks of endless waiting and we
are finally back with fresh one-piece
contents and just how the yonko zaga has
ended with a massive bang the new loft
tail saga has just started off with an
even bigger one and of course the only
correct way to start is by addressing
the man the myth the living legend of
one piece shanks who actually has been
in less than a dozen chapters of one
piece overall in other words whenever he
is there big things are happening and
that is exactly what we've got shanks is
literally sailing in the waters of wano
just a few miles away from where luffy
is celebrating his victory with the
citizens right now and holy usopp there
is so much going on in the few panels he
gets here first of all shanks reveals
that he will not be meeting with luffy
right now not
which is hilarious because i actually
have a video coming out in two or three
days about why when and where shanks and
luffy will meet and what will most
likely happen i said that this meeting
is going to happen very soon most likely
on elbaf then it was rumored that shanks
was going to be in this chapter close to
wano so i changed the script only to
read it and find out that he's only
doing a kind of drive-by around wano
which as you can imagine gave me a bit
of a headache anyways i have a full
video about what will happen between
luffy and shanks very soon so make sure
to subscribe if you don't want to miss
that it's gonna blow your mind i promise
but for now let's focus on the chapter i
think we just all have to accept that
the kind and funny things that we got to
know in early one ps is long gone as we
have learned throughout the story with
shanks stopping kaido stopping the war
meeting the gorosei and so on and so
forth and as this chapter confirms
shanks is one of the most powerful
pirates in the world and a master
manipulator he has been pulling the
strings and guided the events of the one
piece world from behind the scenes
competing with the likes of blackbeard
and the world government to prepare for
his dream of the future whatever that
might be honestly i always took shanks
to be more of a pacifist someone who
would try to avoid battle if somewhat
possible he doesn't fight higuma until
he threatens luffy he stopped kaido from
turning the ward marine fort into the
apocalypse basically he stopped the war
completely and overall it felt like he
was a pretty peace loving guy with
enough power to back that up and i think
that's also what gave shanks a bit of a
bad reputation among fans with many
theorizing that shanks might be the
weakest yonko and only has reached his
level through some sort of trick or
manipulation as well well i think that
this chapter has now turned this belief
completely on its head shanks comes
across here as colts calculated and very
very much willing to fight it turns out
that he indeed has a number of
territories in the new world just like
all the other yonko and that bartolomeo
burning his flag and replacing it with
luffy's will have some very serious
repercussions for him to say the least
as many people have predicted shanks is
seriously coming for his head and he
doesn't sound all too happy that he
works under luffy i need to take care of
my credibility damn this really gave me
shivers i'm not gonna lie shanks is the
real deal and bartolomeo is in some
serious trouble and as if this weren't
enough already shanks also announces
that it's time to join the fight for the
one piece no more standing by and
letting things develop shanks will now
take the stage and actively participate
no wonder that oda and his staff are so
excited for film rats as am i this
sounds like there is a lot of conflict
between luffy and shanks luffy's
underling basically stole one of
shanks's islands and now he tells ben
beckman it's time to join the fight for
the one piece a battle between the four
yonko four love tale luffy shanks buggy
and blackbeard and so all of this of
course brings up the old question
whether shanks might not actually be the
bad guy in disguise again wait for my
video in a few days but i think one
really important hint that we get in
this chapter in particular are shanks's
men they are over the moon to read the
news about luffy defeating kaido they're
all dying to meet luffy in a really
positive way lucky roo bong punch lime
juice they all are excited to finally
reunite with the boy that they met so
many years ago and had so much fun with
to me this indicates that shanks also
doesn't shut up about luffy all the time
either that all of the red hat pirates
have been eager to meet luffy for years
they all truly seem to be luffy's
friends here they are surprised by
shane's not wanting to meet luffy right
now as we are and so i think shanks
acting this way is really just oda
sensei knowing exactly how to play with
us by leaving this ambiguous on purpose
because really the only way that shanks
could turn out to be a bad guy i think
is if he had also fooled his entire crew
which yes is not impossible but also not
exactly likely and so i want shanks to
be the secret weapon that luffy can rely
on in the ends then again if shanks
actually does turn out to be only using
luffy and that he's mostly in it for
himself or some other motive i wouldn't
be mad at all either just so we get that
out of the way in truth if i had to bet
money on it the reality probably falls
somewhere between the two shanks is an
ally and does care for luffy but he has
a higher hidden motive as well that
comes before that i think shanks might
well turn out to be one of the most
morally complex and interesting
characters in the entire story at the
end i also absolutely love that little
flashback to the very first chapter of
the story that we get and a look at
shanks stealing the nika fruit i mean it
was already pretty much obvious that
shanks knew exactly what he was doing
there and what that fruit truly was but
it's nonetheless giving me goosebumps
seeing it drawn and how he reacts to
luffy's awakening it's almost as if
luffy awakening the nika fruit was the
signal that shanks has been waiting for
to launch the race for lovetail and of
course i am incredibly excited to
finally see the red hair pirates in
actions especially lucky roo and ben
beckman and i love that yasob is not
emotionally prepared to face his son yet
that he abandoned as a kid back in her
village like the most heartless father
there is i also want to remind you that
no one not a single man in shanks's crew
has eaten a devil fruit for some
mysterious reason most likely related to
the one piece in other words this is a
yonko crew purely based on power and
skill alone which is really as
impressive as it gets if we're being
honest the only thing that's mysterious
now and that i'm really curious about is
why shanks was hanging around wano in
the first place if it wasn't to see
luffy did he come for pluton however
what i think is even more likely is
actually that shanks has come for
kaido's poneglyph after all shanks
himself hasn't been to love tale before
so maybe he still needed that one for
his collection too that would actually
make a ton of sense now that i think
about it and what would be even more
hilarious of course if shanks didn't
possess the last poneglyph after all but
now has kaidos because the straw hats
were too slow to actually get it someone
else who has made use of kaido's defeat
and is very much eager to meet luffy in
person on the other hand is green bull i
still really can't shake the feeling
that he might actually be from wano
himself i went to detail on that in this
video right here but this chapter
focuses mostly on him being even more of
a beast than we have already seen last
chapter kinemon and the remaining
scabbards notice him moving towards the
capital and decide to stop him before he
can disturb luffy and the straw hats and
so ryokugyu really hits home the fact
that he's kind of a douche he gives
kinemon and ko a big speech about the
world order and how you need to
discriminate in order to make the world
work for the celestial dragons that is
of course
sounds like he's rejecting a little bit
there maybe however the power that he
unleashes is absolutely ridiculous and
the real deal i really don't want to
know how crazy a battle between two of
the admirals might really look this is
just ridiculous actually scratch that
there is nothing i want to see more
right now than seeing two admirals i
actually made the argument in my green
bull video that aramaki might very well
be a logia fruit user which surprisingly
is confirmed right now one chapter later
the fact that he calls himself a force
of nature and compares his forest
abilities to the sea raises two
incredibly interesting possibilities for
me as well one since greenville falls in
line with all the other admiral devil
fruit powers i think we should assume
that fujitora's devil fruit also is a
logia though i really couldn't tell you
how that would make any sense but it
seems very likely now and two aramaki
has just pushed the door wide open for a
sea logia devil fruit like i can't be
the only one that takes this line as
some possible foreshadowing for this
right the ultimate devil fruit possibly
in the possession of emu whose name as
you'll remember is umi in return which
literally is the word for ocean in
japanese i think this theory has gotten
quite a boost with this statement then
yamato and momo step in hands oh boy all
the people who doubted where yamato
would be ranked inside the straw hats i
think it's pretty close to the top the
fact that she can knock this monster
down like this and the ryokugyu mentions
how powerful her haki is really warms my
heart yamato has really become my
favorite character in the series
together with zorro at least maybe even
a tiny little bit more and seeing her
handing it to one of the most powerful
people in the world is just so
satisfying to me i'm of course really
curious to see how momo will hold up
against him one versus one as well momo
has grown a lot throughout the raid on
onigashima physically and mentally but
as his failed border breath shows us he
is far from actually being on kaido's
level with his devil fruit and then
there is of course the entire sabo
situation and it is really reassuring to
hear that it was cobra after all and not
vivi that has been killed and that sabo
has not been captured to start a second
round of marineford and i'm really
fascinated by this new character we're
introduced to head of the marine
criminal investigation server's kudo uma
which means black horse and not only
does this introduce an entirely new
branch of the marines to us but i'm very
much intrigued by the fact that this man
follows the naming scheme of the other
admiral in other words color plus animal
black horse red dog and so on and so
forth correct me if i'm wrong but it
does sound a lot to me like oda sensei
just dropped another admiral level
character out of nowhere into the story
and i'm of course all for it the real
question of course now is what has
happened to sabo and vivi but luckily
for you you don't have to wonder about
that at all because i have already made
an entire video about exactly that that
seems to have hit the nail pretty much
on its head